ich weiß nicht was ihr dazu sagt aber
ich finde das so geisteskrankheit wenn
ich mich damit ich war so froh wenn ich
zwei spiele hatte und jedes spiel hat 50
euro gekostet auch noch und hier sind
einfach 9000 spiele drauf all das was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video sollte ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich freue mich heute ganz
besonders ich kann endlich etwas
auspacken was ich halt gerne auspacken
würde wenn ich mich zurückerinnere ich
weiß dass ich mit vier oder fünf jahren
meinen ersten eigenen game boy bekommen
habe ich weiß die meisten fahren die
höheren von euch wissen gar nicht mehr
was das ist ich kann euch hier super
gerne foto ein band das war ein game boy
hat früher bestimmt 250 300 euro
gekostet und dazu musstest du dann noch
alle spiele kaufen jedes spielern auch
nochmal 50 60 euro kostet das war dann
so platz für die kunst für hinten
reinstellen und wenn ich dann so was
hier sehe da frage ich mich wieso bin
ich denn nicht jetzt groß geworden wir
haben hier eine 3000 plus spiele 16
gigabyte ram psp psp ja also es ist
keine playstation portable sieht dem
ganzen zwar relativ ähnlich aber eine
psp haben wir hier nicht ich wundere
mich dass das hier steht mit 3000
integrierten spielen für 22 euro 19 also
ok warten ehe das war teuer okay gut 27
eur 32 auch noch günstig wenn ich das
wäre ja das paradies gewesen für mich
früher produktbeschreibung pieper
beachtet ist nur irgendwelche
fachbegriff hier müssen wir uns gar
nicht mit auseinander setzen wir schon
einmal noch ganz kurz in die bewertungen
lauf ist bis auf retro gaming zu
exzellenter zustand blablabla also im
großen und ganzen ja gut dreieinhalb
sterne bewertung ist jetzt nicht so gut
ich will das jetzt einfach weil ich bin
sehr gespannt welche spiele darauf sind
die hat 3000 spiele einfach so da drin
für 27 euro auf der einen seite macht
mich das total traurig und auf der
anderen denke ich mir wie ist so was
halt möglich das ist schon krass wie
sich das alles so verändert hat
so hier haben wir das ding auch schon
ich bin sehr gespannt wie die qualität
davon sein wird ich weiß ich ihr könnt
ihr habt ihr so was schon mal gesehen
habt ihr zuhause auf vielleicht ich bin
da nicht auf dem neuesten stand muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen gibt es in
deutschland irgendwie so auch so was für
30 euro bei media markt oder in 3000 von
so retro games oder irgendwelche spiele
drauf sondern schreibe das super gerne
in die kommentare
hier steht jetzt eigentlich auf der
verpackung nichts weiter interessantes
drauf außer was für formate das
unterstützt wir haben hier eine
auflösung von 720 x 480 30 fps ja gut
das ist jetzt nicht das beste aber für
27 euro würde ich da gar nicht mehr ein
game boy von damals weiß ich nicht was
da für eine auflösung hatte aber
wahrscheinlich deutlich schlechter das
ist das ding ist auf ich habe gedacht
vielleicht weil das war schon oft so man
sieht das bild dabei riss bekommen das
produkt und es ist halt kleinmann hatte
sich das viel größer vorgestellt hier
ist es allerdings voll okay auch die
qualität ist voll in ordnung wir haben
hier ja hier kann man die anmachen okay
das haben wir noch auf ladekabel und
hiermit kann man das wahrscheinlich dann
sogar mit tatsächlich mit dem fernseher
verbinden also so sieht das aus wie halt
ne psp damals außer man hat glaube ich
alle knöpfe die man braucht wobei ich
mich an meine psp aber nicht mehr so
genau erinnern kann hier haben wir dann
noch kopfhörer und
eine anleitung ok mal gucken vielleicht
ist dir aufgeladen wir machen die
einfach mal an ach so
moment mal kurz das wir haben hier
einmal diesen powerknopf da wird
wahrscheinlich jedes kind heutzutage
drauf drückt man sich fragen warum das
nicht angeht früher bei den gameboys und
in nintendos gab es hier dieses dingen
zum verschieben und das muss man hier
einfach auch zur seite schieben nach
rechts und dann geht das ding
sah so leute die ist jetzt hoch gefahren
ich habe mir noch eine andere kammer
hingestellt damit ihr das sehen könnt
wir haben jetzt wirklich absolute
classic games super-mario gut contra
kann ich nicht das ist wahrscheinlich
noch vor meiner zeit gewesen dann
dragonball tecan 3 und dann haben wir
hier unten sogar soja
game music pictures videos er wirklich
drauf
videos jetzt geht gar nichts mehr hallo
machen wir das einfach wie früher das
hat auch immer geholfen wenn sich der
game mal aufgaben hat aus und wieder an
ok dann lasse ich besser erstmal vom
mini hier unten die finger einer ganz
kurzen muss einer in die einstellung
rein gucken was denn hier kommt power
saving display language okay kann man
das sogar auf alter wir haben ja sogar
nein doch deutsch wo ist dein deutsch
dass dinge beherrscht sogar die deutsche
sprache nicht schlecht jetzt muss ich
das nur noch auswählen okay das haben
wir und jetzt starte ich immer rein ich
würde super gerne einfach mal super
mario spielen sechseinhalb stunden
später irgendwie habe ich gerade das
problem die spiele gehen gar nicht an
das steht aber definitiv bei 3000
integrierte spiele ich zehn bis jetzt
hier nur 12 aber
vielleicht
aha hektik
so lässt man
okay weil ich wusste ich musste es ihr
euch ganz fürs einmal zeigt ich konnte
jetzt mal gerade die deutsche sprache
einstellen deutsche sprache schwere
sprache und wir gehen einfach mal kurz
hier auf super mario und dann steht da
einfach jetzt ist die deutsche sprache
schon wieder weg jetzt drücke ich
nämlich auch super mario und dann steht
einfach oben neu starten ich dachte ich
schaffe das gerät neu aber damit ist
allgemein super-mario staaten irgendwie
da wird was durcheinander gemacht oder
ich bin dumm keine ahnung teuerung ist
irgendwie noch nicht so unfreundlich
bin das doch gar nicht
ja wenn ich denn überhaupt
also wir werden noch nicht so ganz
nahmen wir beide ich muss mich noch mal
ein bisschen rein fuchsen und macht
ihren kath bis gleich
okay leute ich hab jetzt glaube ich
alles gecheckt und ich muss sagen ich
bin schon immer noch begeistert also wir
machen die noch mal an ich wollte ja
gerade mit dem fernseher connecten
leider hat mein fernseher dieser
anschlüsse nicht das hätte ich super
gerne getestet damit an so ein riesen
fan sein mit so etwas ja auch verrückt
gewesen auf jeden fall ich habe eben
immer mit diesen knöpfen hier gesteuert
das geht irgendwie nicht man muss diesen
knopf nehmen um die figur zu bewegen
hätte ich auch drauf kommen können dann
können wir hier mal runter gehen moment
weil ihr zum beispiel werden jetzt hier
wirklich nur zwölf spieler angezeigt man
geht dann hier einmal auf spiele dann
auf bild in games englisch dann jetzt
aber doch wieder deutlich verzeichnis
liste und dann sieht man hier alle
spiele die drauf sind das sind wirklich
eine menge also soweit ich das jetzt
hier zählen kann tatsächlich
9000 drei spiele wobei ich mir was das
ist ich könnte jetzt einfach bis ganz
unten scrollen aber dass wir irgendwie
zu doof das muss man sich mal vorstellen
9000 spiele darauf und da kann man hier
einfach irgend eines auswählen drückt
dann neu starten dann wird das spiel
geöffnet und du kannst es zocken ich
weiß nicht was ihr das zu sagt aber ich
finde das so geisteskrankheit wenn ich
mich damit ich war so froh wenn ich zwei
spiele hatte und jedes spiel hat 50 euro
gekostet auch noch und hier sind einfach
9000 spiele drauf dann kann man hier
eigentlich einfach start drücken
und dann geht's auch schon los wir sind
hier lanzelot und können dann jetzt hier
gegen diese dinge ins provinz kämpfen
das spiel fand ich irgendwie scheiße ich
habe jetzt noch mal ein anderes
gestartet pedelecs dinosaurs also
da war ich noch nicht auf der welt
kommen
vorher vom ersten band nicht mit ihr
kollege und der nächste kumpel
bam bam und der entgegen
um weiße alte auch schön weitermachen
weitermachen
haben wir haben die schlage ich bin
gewalt er ist so was habe ich früher
immer gesagt es war nicht dieses spiel
jetzt habe ich noch nie gehört aber
also halten wir noch mal kurz fest hier
sind anscheinend wirklich 9000 spiele
drauf die bildqualität ist an sich ganz
okay so sagen halt die spiele damals aus
die soundqualität ist der absolute flop
also mein gameboy von 2002 oder 2003
klang deutlich besser trotzdem finde ich
dieses ding heißt also da kann man nicht
meckern für das geld so viele spiele
wenn der langeweile hast talks halt ein
bisschen und da gibt es ja so viel was
man ausprobieren kann und ich wette ich
werde noch ganz ganz viele spiele wieder
finden die ich früher gespielt habe ich
kann nichts schlechtes dazu sagen jetzt
auf jeden fall spaß gemacht ja so sieht
das aus und wir sehen uns morgen 19
wieder ich hoffe dass wir dadurch
gefallen schickt mir gern weitere sache
nicht testen soll das war es von mir
haut rein abonniert den kanal ach so
können gern mal kommentieren was ihr mit
der dinge zu machen würdet und wenn ich
die nicht benutzen sollte schicke ich
die irgendein kommentare schreiben zu
das war's haut rein
[Musik]